من بعد اكثر من شهر يعني على حضر تيك توك
في الاردن شركه تيك توك اخيرا خرجت عن
صمتها واصدرت بيان امس اعلنت في المحادثات
بينها وبين الحكومه الاردنيه لرفع الحظر
عن التطبيق وقال البيان انه الشركه بتؤمن
بالتوصل لقرار يسمح لي المنصه مواصله خدمه
الملايين من صانعي المحتوى والمستخدمين في
الاردن وعرض البيانات عن هاشتاج مفيده مثل
ليرن تيك توك اللي هي مثلا شيء تعليمي
وقالت انه عليه
354 مليون مشاهده في الاردن تحديدا وهشتاق
مثلا
138 مليون مشاهده في الاردن ايضا بيان تيك
توك تاكد كمان انه فرق الشركه راح تواصل
اتخاذ الاجراءات ضد اي محتوى بنت هيك
القواعد الاجتماعي
310,000 مقطع مخالف في الاردن اكثر من
يعني في الميه منهم ان شالوا قبل ما
يحصدوا اي مشاهدات وهذا انه يعني يعني تبر
دليل على انه عندهم سرعه في الاجراءات
طبعا للتذكير مشاهدين لان احنا وحده
الجرائم الالكترونيه في الاردن اعلنت في
بيان في ديسمبر عن ايقاف تطبيق تيك توك
مؤقتا لعدم تعامل المنصه مع اساءه
استخدامها من قبل بعض المستخدمين سواء
بمجدوه او بينشروا اعمال العنف او دعوات
الفوضى وكان هذا خلال احتجاجات على ارتفاع
اسعار المحروقات تخللتها اعمال عنف ووفاه
عقيده الاردنيين من نفس القرار تحولوا
لتطبيقات في بي ان للتحويل على الحظر
واستخدام تيك توك وعامر فيديوهات من هناك
او حتى من الصوت الاخرى في اردنيين جنسي
بين نجد السلطات انه يرجعوا لهم تيك توك
وبيانات لشركه سمبل للتحليلات اظهرت اقبال
كبير على تطبيقات الفي بي ان في الاردن
وزياده كبيره في مرات التحميل هذه
التطبيقات تصدرت قوائم اكثر تحميلا على
متجر اب ستور الايام الماضيه واحتلت
المراتب الاربعه الاولى ام على متجر جوجل
بلاي احتلت الفي بي ان خمس مراتب من ال 10
مراتب للتطبيقات الاكثر تحميلا اما اخر
التصريحات الصادره عن الحكومه الاردنيه
فكانت من يومين وعلى لسان وزير الاقتصاد
الرقمي والاردن احمد الهنانده اللي قال
انه ما في اي اخبار او يعني عوده التطبيق